a video gone viral on tick tock is
generating buzz but for not the reasons
you might think the clip was recorded
during a recent ccsd meeting and now an
investigation is underway
i'm going to read you an assignment
given to my
15 year old daughter at a local high
school kendra evans appears to be
rattled as she stands before the clark
county school district board last week
the mother claiming her daughter was
upset about what her high school teacher
assigned her to memorize in front of her
class and sharing a portion with the
board i don't love you it's not you it's
just
i don't like your
or anything in that case ccsd board
members quickly stopped the public
comment over the derogative language and
the mic is turned off that moment
captured on social media on a popular
tick tock page claiming adults can't
handle hearing this content yet they
readily give it to kids in school in the
original feed from ccsd evans has given
her time to speak saying this about her
15 year old daughter we have
pornography laws regarding minors in
this state and many of those were
violated because of this assignment
while we're not
allowed to engage back and forth on a
dialogue we would absolutely like to
make sure that your concerns are
addressed ccsd via twitter says they are
investigating the circumstances
surrounding the class assignment evans
stated she didn't want the teacher fired
but hopes by addressing the matter it
will avoid the problem from happening
again
if you would like to see the complete
video we posted a link on our website
that's 8newsnow.com